it's sometimes difficult to reconcile
that Diablo 3 is over a decade old its
release was polarizing for a number of
reasons but its evolving formula of
action role-playing endured enjoying a
Resurgence with his post-launch
expansion that carried through years of
ongoing seasonal updates it shouldn't
come as a surprise then that each of
those years helped inform the design of
Diablo 4 a game which confidently
delivers gameplay that has been carried
forward and refined from Diablo 2 and 3.
while also establishing a strong
foundation for the franchise's future
Diablo games have always contained
stories for their single player
campaigns but you'd be forgiven for
thinking of past storylines as merely
contextualization for the game's primary
focus dungeon crawling that's where
Diablo 4 makes one of its most striking
changes it not only takes its story far
more seriously but it tells one that's
far more engrossing than ever before as
a traveling Wanderer you come across a
small town of villages on a snow-capped
mountain range looking for some Aid
after killing some creatures and
returning you're welcomed as a hero and
given food and shelter only for the
villagers to try and use you in a ritual
sacrifice to Lilith co-creator of
sanctuary and recently resurrected
antagonists of this tale this encounter
links you to Lilith driving you forward
on a quest to stop her plan of amassing
an army for her own nefarious purposes
by mother's blood
thy mother's body
so shall you with this hell Glory
for you die much of that sounds like
stand at Diablo Fair there's a big bad
demon and you're the only one who can
stop it but Diablo 4 makes intelligent
use of Lilith layering her motivation
slowly to the point where you can't help
but consider her side of the argument
she's not driven solely by a Lust For
Destruction instead she's grieving with
the place she once created to escape the
endless cycle of War Between Heaven and
Hell now being used as a staging ground
to continue it she's an antagonist that
has been slighted by those she trusted
at every turn and while her means of
exacting Justice provide the reason for
your entire crusade in the first place
it's surprising and equally welcome when
Diablo 4 forces you to slow down and
consider the true goal of your struggle
not just any demon
the daughter of hatred the mother of
sanctuary the trop of the Soul Survivor
has been tried and tested in Diablo for
years and Diablo 4 doesn't completely
change that instead it puts a much
larger emphasis on companions than ever
before with most acts centered around a
new party member rather than a demon
you're eventually hunting down an early
standout is Vigo a prideful Knight who
is forced to endure a conscious ruining
loss after a single selfish action it's
not just vigo's remorse that is
heart-wrenchingly conveyed but also the
horrors of his eventual Redemption
leading to one of the more powerful
character moments in the entire game
vigo's story is a teaser for many
similar arcs that follow all of which do
a great job of providing a cause for
your character to join your fight while
also contextualizing their motivations
to continue or abstain from the enduring
conflict this applies to most of the
Allies you recruit in your fight against
the lift Each of which has their own
motivations that feel faithful to their
respective Journeys it's a level of care
I can't recall being given to many past
Diablo Companions and Diablo 4 certainly
makes far more liberal use of them
through the campaign to make them feel
purposeful bringing together this ragtag
group takes place over Diablo 4's
extensive sex acts some of which you can
tackle in different orders previous
Diablo titles had each Act accompanied
by a change in Locale but in Diablo 4 it
only takes a few moments before you're
given free reign to explore its
intimidatingly large interconnected map
here you can transition from frigid
mountaintops to desolate deserts in just
a matter of minutes with the
transitional areas doing a good job of
masking an otherwise jarring change
having a static layout that you can
learn and get comfortable with induced
Exploration with a greater sense of
wonder than previous hubs which were
often filled with enemies to kill before
diving into the next dungeon the
geography also gives towns and larger
cities a sense of place on a bigger map
each distinct area is shown off of a
great amount of visual detail with
Diablo 4 incorporating a delightfully
Macabre style that is befitting of its
violent story it's not trying to overly
correct some of the criticisms laid on
Diablo 3 either with pops of color used
Tastefully to highlight areas of Hope
and kinship that contrast against the
broader Strokes of dread and fear
painting the rest of the landscape
things don't always hold up when the
camera Zooms in to give conversations a
cinematic feel as a degradation in
detail on character models and
environments is a little more
discernible regardless it's still a
striking presentation that looks
incredible in motion while also keeping
information clear enough to read when
fights get chaotic
no one else
the moment-to-moment action Diablo 4 is
one of its strongest traits which is for
the best given how genre defining the
series has been over the years there's
an argument to be made that Diablo 3
went too far in the direction of
simplification and that's exactly where
Diablo 4 course corrects in smart ways
you're still limited to a total of six
Active abilities at a time four on your
Hotbar and two on each Mouse button for
those on PC but how you construct your
build is no longer linear instead each
new level lets you invest a point in a
branching skill tree with each of its
core notes branching further out into
new abilities and Associate passive
perks you need to invest a certain
number of total points that continue
unlocking each of these nodes so you
will have to think carefully about
abilities and how they serve your
greater build it's a system that allows
for a lot of flexibility letting you
experiment with focusing on one specific
ability as the foundation of your build
or dabbling with ways to combine two
entirely different paths such as
empowering your summon skeletons while
also firing off loads of blood infused
magic as a necromancer
oh
foreign
[Applause]
experimentation is further encouraged by
Diablo 4's low cost to respect and
unlimited chances to do so unlike the
more punishing approach in Diablo 2 you
can completely redefine your build at
any time for a small fee of in-game gold
approaching your skill tree with a
different idea or mindset or just making
some small changes to adjust for a
difficult fight this freedom is
empowering in a similar way to that of
Diablo 3's fluid build system but it
still requires you to engage
meaningfully with synergies to make your
builds viable it feels like the
culmination of all the ways previous
games in the series have allowed you to
play while catering to as many play
Styles as possible but without many of
the critical compromises from the last
time out the cost for respect does
naturally increase the higher level but
I never got to a point where I felt it
was too expensive in relation to the
amount of gold I was earning at the time
thanks to this system I felt free to
continually change up my approach to my
Necromancer I started with a combination
of skeleton summoning Shadow damage and
attacks and some blood spells for
survivability the necromancer's unique
ability lets me either summon minions
from corpses or sacrifice the ability
entirely for Passive advantage Pages
which led me to realize that I could
theoretically play a necromancer
entirely as a pseudo-mage with Blood and
Bone abilities after some taxing boss
battles I decided to go all in on a
summoning build that accentuated the
abilities of my skeleton soldiers Mages
and large hulking Golem Each of which
had three different variations I could
combine to find the perfect Synergy it
was consistently satisfying to find a
build that worked for a couple of hours
and then completely change it either
through necessity or curiosity seeing
small decisions manifest as big changes
in terms of overall viability gives me
faith that each class is going to be
picked apart for various approaches that
maximize elements of different play
Styles while the skill tree is where you
will ultimately establish the basis of
your build aspects of power or a new
facet of the role-playing formula that
allows you to hone it these collectible
skills so to speak can be combined with
rare pieces of gear to turn them into
custom legendary items imbued with the
exact ability that complements the build
you're constructing this alleviates some
of the headaches associated with
grinding out dungeons in the hopes of a
particularly legendary piece of gear
dropping while also providing a new
Avenue of options for build construction
that isn't to say it diminishes the rush
of a big legendary drop though Legendary
Weapons can often feature the same
abilities as aspects do but will
regularly have better percentage roles
on their effectiveness making them the
ideal path to the most optimal late game
build still
aspects of Power are obtained by
clearing the many dungeons sprawl around
the map Each of which feature their own
multi-stage objective to complete some
are as simple as killing enemies and
depositing their souls to progress
further While others require you to hunt
down a specific foe in search of a key
that lets you reach lower levels of the
dungeon each of these concludes with a
boss fight which for the most part are
less interesting than those found in the
main story dungeons bosses throughout
the story are multi-layered bouts with
shifting enemy attacks that can
completely change the landscape you're
fighting in forcing you to consistently
think about positioning and when the
best moment for an attack is bosses in
these more common dungeons lack that
sense of complexity and I often found
masculine Warriors completely
overwhelming many of them to the point
where many of the bosses would just
stand in place and attack until dead
thank you
given the sheer number of dungeons on
offer it might not have been possible to
retain the same level of tension across
every boss encounter but when you're
bouncing between several of these as you
grab aspects of power throughout your
campaign it's difficult not to notice
the Stark contrasting quality between
the two as with any Diablo title Diablo
4 is nowhere near complete once you've
rolled credits on the campaign Walter's
return to incentivize you to go through
everything again with a high degree of
difficulty but also more rewards to reap
it's welcomed that Diablo 4 retains the
option that allows you to jump into more
challenging World tiers from the very
start this time preventing a potentially
frustrating first playthrough devoid of
any meaningful challenge outside of
increasing world here the map becomes
littered with additional side activities
that join regular side quests rotating
open mode Dynamic quests similar to the
Patrols in Destiny 2 and strongholds
strongholds are extremely hostile areas
that are densely populated with enemies
usually a level or two higher than you
providing a larger challenge to overcome
than regular groups or foes around the
open world minor objectives also make
this feel like a smaller scale open-air
dungeon with new waypoints and Merchants
usually unlocked once you've read the
area of the threat
so
larger-scale World boss fights that are
best tackled with numerous other players
you will find in the open world are also
available although no multiplayer
features were available during the
review period finally Whispers of the
Dead encapsulate time bounties that pop
up throughout the world with each one
rewarding you with an additional
currency that can be turned in for
caches of gems weapons and More Night
messages which can be obtained through
completing Whispers of the Dead quests
can be used to unlock additional
nightmare dungeons these add new
modifiers to existing dungeons around
the map that can do anything from change
the type of enemies you encounter to
Rolling new random abilities they might
have at their disposal with the Allure
of even rarer loot drops enticing you to
run them over and over again
yeah
there's a familiar but equally expensive
framework in place already in Diablo 4
that should satiate you across multiple
playthroughs with plans already detailed
by a blizzard to expand on this through
seasons of new content similar to that
of Diablo 3. now
true work begins
Diablo 4 at this time cannot Escape
comparison to the past of the franchise
it belongs to but it's thankfully a game
that has been crafted with a strong
awareness of what made each one either
revered or reviled it represents a
measured approach to combining the many
elements from previous entries that
worked into a system that feels like the
new standard Bearer for Action
role-playing coupled with a new
Benchmark for storytelling in the
franchise and a solid narrative
foundation for any potential new
adventures it's easy to see a Diablo 4
as something I'll regularly check out
for a long time to come
[Music]
it unlocked and lost our path to the
Future
a future made possible because of the
price you paid
[Music]
your sacrifice
will not have been in vain